This lecture is the first one about the
text clustering.
This is very important that technique
for doing topic mining an analysis.
In particular, in this lecture organ to
start with some basic questions about
the clustering: What is text clustering and why we are interested in text clustering?
In the following lectures, we're going
to talk about how to do text clustering
and how to evaluate the clustering
results.
So what is text
clustering
?
Clustering actually is a very general
technique for data mining.
As you might have learned in some other
courses.
The idea is to discover natural
structures in the data.
In other words, we want to group
similar objects together.
In our case, these objects are of
course texture objects.
For example, they can be documents,
turns, passages, sentences or websites.
And then our goal is to group similar
texture objects together.
So let's see a example here.
You don't really see text objects,
but I just use some shapes to denote
objects that can be grouped together.
Now, if I ask you what are some natural
structures or natural groups well you,
if you look at it, you might agree that
we can group these objects based on
shapes or their locations on this 2
dimensional space.
So we got the three clusters in this
case.
And then may not be so much
disagreement about these three
clusters, but it really depends on the
perspective to look at the objects.
Maybe some of you have also seen it in
a different way, so we might get
different clusters.
And you will see another example about this
ambiguity more clearly, but the main
point here is the problem is actually
not so well defined.
And the problem lies in how to define
similarity.
What do you mean by similar objects?
Now this problem.
Has to be clearly defined in order to
have well defined clustering problem.
And the problem is in general that any
two objects can be similar that depending
on how you look at them.
So for example.
Let's look at the two words like car
and horse.
So are the two words similar
It depends on how you look at it.
If you look at the physical.
Physical properties of car and horse.
They are very different.
But if you look at the them
functionally, a car in the horse can
both be transportation tool, so in that
sense they may be similar.
So as you can see, it really depends on
our perspective to look at the objects
and so in order to make the clustering
problem well defined, a user must
define the perspective.
For assessing similarity.
And we call this perspective the
clustering bias.
And when you define a clustering
problem, it's important to specify your
perspective for similarity or for
defining the similarity that would be
used to group similar objects 'cause
otherwise.
Similarity is not well defined.
An one can have different ways to group
objects.
So let's look at a concrete example.
Here you are seeing some objects or
some shapes that are very similar to
what you have seen on the 1st slide.
But if I ask you to group these objects
again, you might.
Might.
Feel there's more uncertainty here than
on the previous slide.
For example.
You might think, well, we can still
group by shapes, so that would give us
cluster that looks like this.
However, you might also feel that.
Maybe the objects can be grouped based
on the sizes, so that would give us a
different way to cluster the data.
If we look at the size and look at the
similarity in size.
So as you can see clearly here,
depending on the perspective will get
different clustering results, so that
also clearly tells us that in order to
evaluate the clustering result we must
use perspective.
Without perspective, it's very hard to
define what is the best clustering
result.
So there are many examples of text
clustering.
Set up.
And so, for example, we can cluster
documents in the whole text
collection.
So in this case documents are the units
to be clustered.
We may be able to cluster terms in this
case.
Terms are objects.
And Cluster of terms can be used to
define the concept or theme or topic.
In fact, the topic models that you have
seen some previous lectures.
Can give you cluster of terms in some
sense.
If you take the terms with high
probabilities from world distribution.
Another example is to just a cluster
any texts segments, for example
passages, sentences or any segments
that you can extract the from a large
text objects.
For example, we might extract all the
text segments about the topic, let's
say by using a topic model.
Now, once we've got those text objects,
then we can cluster.
The segments that we've got to discover
interesting clusters that might also
represent the subtopics.
So this is a case of combining text
clustering with some other techniques,
and in general you will see a lot of
text mining algorithms can be actually
combined in a flexible way to achieve.
The goal of doing more sophisticated
mining and analysis of text data.
We can also cluster fairly large text
law gets, and by that I just mean text
objects may contain a lot of documents.
So for example we might cluster
websites.
Each website is actually composed of
multiple documents.
Similarly, we can also cluster articles
written by the same author, for
example.
So we can treat all the articles
published by author as one unit for
Clustering.
In this way, we might group authors
together based on whether they are
published papers or similar.
Furthermore, text clusters can also be
further clustered.
Regenerate the hierarchy that that's
'cause we can in general, cluster any
text object at different levels.
So more generally, why is text
clustering interesting?
Well, it's brcause it's a very
useful technique for text mining,
particularly exploratory text analysis.
And so a typical scenario is that you
are getting a lot of text data.
Let's say all the email messages from
customers in some time period, or all
the literature, articles, etc.
And then you hope to get the sense
about what are the overall content of
the collection.
So, for example, you might be
interested in getting.
A sense about the major topics or what
are some typical or representative
document in the collection?
And clustering help us achieve this
goal.
We sometimes also want to link similar
text objects together and these.
These objects might be duplicated
content for example, and in that case
such a technique can help us remove
redundancy, removing duplicated
documents.
Sometimes they are about the same topic
and by linking them together we can
have more complete coverage of the
topic.
We may also use text the clustering to
create a structure on the text data,
and sometimes we can create a hierarchy
of structures and this is very useful
for browsing.
We may also use text clustering to
induce additional features to represent
text data when we cluster documents
together, we can treat each cluster as
a feature and then we can say when a
document is in this cluster and then
the feature value would be one and if a
document is not in this cluster, then
the future value is zero and this helps
provide additional discrimination that
might be used for texture
classification as we will discuss
later.
So there are in general many
applications of text clustering any.
I just saw it with two very specific
ones.
One is to cluster search results for
example and
You can imagine a search engine can
cluster the search results so that user
can see overall structure of those.
Results returned for a query.
And when the query is ambiguous, this
is particularly useful.
Becausw clusters likely represent
different senses of ambiguous word.
Another application is to understand
the major complaints from customers
based on their emails, right?
So in this case we can cluster email
messages and then find the major
clusters.
From there.
We can understand what other major
complaints about.